OMAR SIDDIQUI: What I love
about gaming, at least
the kinds of games
we make, they're
really interactive storytelling.
My name is Omar Siddiqui.
I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Kiwi.
Our titles are immersive,
character-oriented.
Over the course of
the last two years,
we've had five that have
been in the top 25 grossing.
The kinds of games
we make require
a few things to be successful.
One, they need to be able to
be distributed really broadly.
Two, they need
the ability for us
to really have analytics
infrastructure.
And third, they really
need robust [INAUDIBLE]
transactions and that whole
monetization infrastructure.
SHVETANK JAIN:
Two years ago when
I was going around and saying
we're starting a new gaming
company and we're going to be
focused on making games only
for Android, I think everyone
looked at me and was like, why?
And two years later,
everyone looks at me
and says that was a
very smart thing to do.
JOHN HSU: What's interesting
about the ecosystem
as Android becomes
so prevalent is
that it's becoming more and
more of a social experience.
You play games, you talk
to your friends about them,
you always have them on you.
And with the
platform itself, you
can actually integrate
and interface
with people, check leaderboards
to see how your friends are
doing, and making it a
comparative social experience.
OMAR SIDDIQUI: Every
six months, the revenue
we've been generating
has been doubling.
It's great to be a part of
that type of growth as well.
SHVETANK JAIN: Some of the
key features of Android
that has really
helped us are being
able to push out APKs
and content immediately
to our users and doing partial
deployment to a segment
of users and test it
out, and then roll it out
to the remaining ones.
And also, the
international penetration
has been really helpful to
be able to reach a larger
audience.
JOHN HSU: When we design
games, we don't just
focus on necessarily creating
an immersive experience.
We recognize that
players are going
to be playing these games on
the train, in boring meetings,
wherever.
And we want to design
experience that's
specifically relevant
for how they're actually
interacting with it.
OMAR SIDDIQUI: At
this point we've
had games that have been on
Google Play for almost two
years now, and they still
have a large community
of players who play
every single day.
And that's our challenge,
is to keep it fresh
and to keep it interesting.